US intelligence officials are in no
doubt Russia tried to influence our 2016
election and believe Moscow will likely
do the same in 2020 Robby Mook was right
in the middle of that 2016 election he
was Hillary Clinton's campaign manager
the molar report says Russia tried to
hurt the Clinton campaign and benefit
her opponent Donald Trump Mook is now
president of the House Majority
political action committee and he joins
us only on CBS this morning Robbie good
morning good morning if as mr. Muller
says his his report is his testimony
what significant do you think we can
learn when he testifies in front of
Congress
I think this is going to be enormous ly
helpful because to hear the White
House's spin on this or frankly
congressional Republicans spent on it
you know the this report totally
exonerated the president he never did
anything wrong everything's fine that's
not true at all if you read this report
it's fairly damning and I think just
having Muller there to speak in person
about it even if he's just repeating the
words that are in there is gonna help
make clear that a lot of bad things
happened and a lot more questions need
to be asked so I'm not concerned at all
if he sticks within the confines of the
report I wish everybody would go read it
because I think they'd be really
troubled but Robby some say we're going
backwards instead of forwards since the
report did say that there was no
collusion and that it's true that they
tried to interfere with our election but
there's no evidence that the Trump
anybody Trump or anyone associated with
the president colluded with them are we
going backwards instead of forwards now
well look politically I think for people
running for office they absolutely need
to look forward and they need to be
addressing you know what's going on in
voters lives I think there's a
completely separate question which is
when the president or his administration
break the law they need to be held
accountable for that and there are
questions in that report about whether
the law was broken the report said it it
wasn't allowed to indict the president
and it wasn't in a position because it
didn't have all the information on the
table to make a decision on that and so
it is well within the purview of the
committee to investigate that matter
and I think they're handling this right
they've got to go find the facts and the
problem is that this administration at
every step has been blocking them and I
I commend the leadership in the
committee for being patient in multiple
committees for being patient and
pursuing methodically all the facts
that's what we got to get and then they
should make a determination okay all
right let's go into the debate yeah
we're moving on to the debates
you helped Hillary Clinton prepare for
debates in 2016 as I recall at most
there were five candidates on the stage
yeah we're gonna have twice as many on
stage tonight how do you prepare a
candidate for that number of people all
at once this is so difficult because for
a debate where you have two three four
people on the stage you can actually
bring people in to rehearse that's
really important to do because you
really want to simulate as much of that
environment as possible you can't do
that here you know these candidates
can't train and bring in ten people you
know or nine other people to do this
with them they're really just gonna have
to think very clearly about what moments
they want to have that really speak to
who they are what's that a big idea or
message as a candidate and do everything
they can to land those but look some
candidates are just never gonna get the
right opportunity at this debate and so
for some of them it's gonna be about
restraint and discipline because just
running out there to land something
every two seconds isn't going well how
critical a moment is it for candidates
these two debates Robbie you know to be
honest with you I hate to say this this
is just the beginning this is not the
be-all end-all it is great if someone
can you know catch a little wind in
their sails but we got a long way to go
months and months to go many more
debates so this is in the end of the
world if it doesn't happen tonight or
tomorrow I know a long way to go but it
starts tonight and I know people are
gonna be trying to make a moment and
we'll be watching Thank You Robbie
always good thank you thanks a lot